foreign
New Jersey hi Jeannie how are you
hi Dave and Jade how are you better than
we deserve what's up
um I need I just need a little bit of
encouragement and some um clarification
on something I heard you say a couple of
um days ago or weeks ago I can't
remember
um I am baby step three I am uh
struggling with getting rid of that last
credit card because I want to buy a
house next year and I do want to do the
manual underwriting but you mentioned
something about
um you're like having a credit card is
more even if you're not using it is more
damaging than not having it
I want my score to be indeterminable but
can that happen if I have a credit card
still open on it no it cannot just tell
me to cut it up cut it up you you cannot
cannot be indeterminal indeterminable
while you have open Credit accounts
anything even if there's zero balances
anything
yes everything has to be completely
closed and zero balance
okay as long as it's open it's still
reporting even if it's reporting a zero
a zero balance
okay I'm already in touch with Churchill
so we're going through stuff but they I
couldn't understand what you how you
explained it before the other day and I
just wanted some
um yeah the damage is is that what you
end up with when you have one credit
card open and a zero balance and no
other credit accounts of any kind you're
going to end up with a low credit score
because you have almost no credit
that's what it amounts to even though
it's not bad it's just you don't have
any you'll be like a 20 year old or
something that just got their first card
and the only thing they have in their
whole life they're not going to have a
high credit score with One credit card
you know and that's that's back that's
back where you are and that's what
you're setting up so because the
algorithm is based on how you interact
the algorithm that creates the credit
scores based on how you interact with
credit it's not based on anything else
and so if you're a zero if you have zero
interaction with credit then that's when
you have an indeterminable a zero credit
score Genie you said you're nervous are
you nervous because you're unsure of
your credit score dropping to zero when
you cut this up are you nervous because
now you won't have this credit card in
your life where's your nerves coming
from specifically I think the nerves are
coming from just having that cushion or
thinking I have a cushion and I don't
want to think that but I just I'm
struggling with myself it's just a
battle it is a battle look I'm going to
validate that because the credit card
companies that's what they tell us they
tell us you can't exist without us you
need us to prop up your life you can't
spend with they they've been telling us
this for decades don't leave home
without don't leave home without it and
I'm 53 so I just started this in in
January I'm just like you know I've been
that stuff has been drilled in me a long
time and you're single yes and so you're
you feel vulnerable you feel a little
bit vulnerable for that reason yeah and
um yeah that that's very normal but what
that tells us is and it that I went
through this you know spiritually myself
some 30 years ago it tells me what I'm
counting on
what am I what is in a in a sense not
not a true spiritual sense but in a
sense what is my God what is my what is
my provision oh my gosh you know okay
I'm gonna do it y'all it's so good but I
mean it tells that's what I had to cope
with I went who's providing for me I
don't like the way you put that I know
but I I that's what I had to have here
in my head and it wasn't like a golden
calf worshiper I'm not saying that
that's not what you're doing but the
thing is this I I figured out I really
can't count on them to make my life good
I can count on me and my hard work and
my diligence and discipline and wisdom
and I can count on God providing for me
my heavenly father who's crazy about me
I can count on those two things but I
100 can't count on Wells Fargo look
exactly that's a word that's it and
that's that's you know who is my
provider and that's that's what they've
done they've gotten their tentacles
around their claws or around that
portion of our heart yeah that says
don't leave home without it don't leave
and that's it turns out Daniel Boone did
instead of relying on credit and credit
scores I I just like give yourself
credit give yourself credit that you can
handle your own money give yourself
credit that you can budget and you're a
big girl and a bit interesting how that
word is interchangeable it is credit as
in I'm gonna go in debt or I'm gonna
give myself credit
cred street cred I'm gonna give myself
the belief in myself I'm putting that in
the quick read and that that's what I'm
thinking yeah you know I I there but
that's why the credit cards have big and
the FICO score really when we talk about
this don't worship at the altar of the
great FICO yeah oh great FICO provider
of all good things we bring you
offerings of Interest so that you give
us a bigger score that has nothing to do
with nothing except how much we play
kissy face with a bank and you know we
we really this is our provider yeah oh
FICO good old FICO and I I think of
these bad B movies with like a you know
like a pyramid with flames coming out of
the top and the you know the the the the
you know the the face the face made out
of stone and there's smoke coming out
the ears yeah great FICO oh great FICO
we worship you you know like we're
Mayans or something oh my God give me a
break no none of that yeah but I mean
that not picking on her but I mean
that's where I was too I I get it we
were convinced the best way to become
wealthy is to go into stay in that yeah
by the people who want you to go into
debt and stay in debt yeah they've
convinced us of that the borrower is
truly slave for the lender good hey we
another one's down she's going to cut it
up Jade she's going to do it she's gonna
do it